can we can we talk about the Braun
comparison mm-hmm yeah is there a much
bigger gap now I think it's gotten
skewed the other way I think we kind of
forgot how great Jordan was and now
we're watching this and I saw some poll
that I got sent where they pulled
everybody and who's better at like
everything you could be better at Jordan
won every single category including
better passer and that's just absurd
Jordan's not a better passer than LeBron
Jordan is better than LeBron and I think
we remember away he's definitively
better when we watch this but now it's
getting the LeBron to slow's yeah it do
you I think there's no denying the fact
that Jordan is way more competitive yeah
and that Jordan has far more control of
the game and I think that's the knock on
LeBron at least for me is that yeah he
can play all the positions and yeah he
can do all this stuff and he's amazing
etcetera
amazing passer facilitator but he can't
control the game the way Jordan can
control the game yeah and he's can
control it very well but he can't do
what Jordan does which is I will just
take over and the fourth nobody else
will touch the ball nobody else needs to
score I will make sure that I score and
if I need to get the stops I'll do that
as well yeah it's kind of like that BJ
Armstrong quote in the first three P
where Jordan has kind of figured out how
to win yeah well he wasn't even playing
the game to play anymore he just was
playing to win yeah
and he just got it and saw the matrix
basically yeah it kind of seemed like
that and LeBron is not quite there yeah
I don't know if LeBron has the
confidence in his offense that Jordan
does yeah I think LeBron has the
confidence in his ability to get the
best shot in the moment for his team
yeah I think he knows how to do that I
don't think he knows how to get the best
shot for himself so I think you see a
lot of times he defers on these
last-second shots because that is the
best shot yeah the best shot is to kick
it to whoever the [ __ ] is in the corner
right yeah but when you need a bucket
sometimes you gotta hoist it you got to
be the one that puts it up and of course
there's been tons of last-second shots
at that LeBron is hit and we can go
throughout history and find him and make
a point for that
absolutely that being said
I think he's limited in his ability I
know this sounds crazy but the amount of
moves that he has that are effective
moves I think he is more limited than
Jordan more limited than Jordan he's
many more moves than most people but
Jordan was unlimited or maybe he had
eight go-to moves they were all
unstoppable yeah I just think the gap is
much bigger and I'm someone who was
ready to hand over the keys to LeBron a
year ago I was probably saying on this
very podcast yo it's on LeBron is the
guy yeah I don't see it that way anymore
and granted maybe I'm skewed by like
this bias you know a documentary but I
just can't I can't give it to them
do you remember why I said I was taking
that conversation off the table which
like a year ago LeBron being the goat it
was because LeBron went to LA and I we
essentially knew this year he's mailing
it in and I was thinking Jordan would
never do that in this documentary I feel
so much more confident in that even in
his second year when Jordan got injured
and they were ready to tank so he get a
lottery player in his second year he was
like that's not how you play the [ __ ]
game we play to win that's what we do
yeah if you're gonna play you play to
win and that's like that to me that
solidified and also that quote as much
as it was overblown and that's Jordans
superpower I think that's the thing that
separates Jordan from LeBron a lot also
is Jordan has no fear of consequences
and it's easier when there's no social
media and all that but like LeBron seems
to get in his head a little bit he'll
makes the right basketball play with
he's calculating more than Jordan
it seems Jordan is how could I be afraid
of a shot I haven't missed yet how could
it be afraid to miss a shot I haven't
taken you that seems crazy to me like
he's in the moment he's just live in
there let's shoot whatever happens
happens I think it'll go in let's go
LeBron seems to be thinking things
through
you know it's like with football Peyton
Manning and Eli Manning Payton is a
definitively better quarterback but Eli
I would trust more on the last Drive of
a game Eli did it twice in the Super
Bowl because to me when I was watching
Eli he's not thinking he's just going
out there and playing yeah and that only
really benefits you there if you're Eli
and Peyton and Peyton is a [ __ ]
genius and see but Peyton was just
always calculating and that's why I
thought Peyton wasn't as clutch as Eli
hmm and I think it's a similar thing but
the talent gap is obviously much closer
with
Jordan and LeBron hmm yeah that's funny
seeing LeBrons quote in his barbershop
show where he's like oh yeah when I beat
when I came back from 3-1 that's when I
became the greatest of all time
like it's just so funny watching him say
that who while watching these docs I'm
like yeah like shut the [ __ ] up so yeah
not close man and I understand because
LeBron is how old 30 he's 35 35 34 35 so
he barely got to experience Jordan right
LeBron's watching this right now and
learning a lot about Jordan not saying
he doesn't know the [ __ ] Jordan is but I
think he's actually learning about the
greatness of Jordan like a lot of
younger people who are watching it like
oh wow I didn't know it was like this
it's hard for LeBron to truly appreciate
Jordan because he's not old enough we
are barely old enough we only got to
appreciate second three-peat if any just
one anyone sit in this room right now
big no I knew who was the greatest the
first three-peat you're lying you don't
remember it you do not remember I
remember thinking he was the greatest
after flu game
what cuz I these kids three-peat was
that second three-peat know exactly to
your point yeah so it's like so LeBron
younger than us yeah by at least two
years right yeah and these are formative
years like this between like seven and
nine is big yeah you know the difference
is 1618 nothing yeah like seven and now
I probably appreciate because I
appreciated it during the last two
finals yeah and how old were you I'm
younger than LeBron how I was 35 he's
about our age and I'm 33 okay so he
experienced that three-peat he
understands greatness and that respect
the second 300 size one yeah that was
two year but I think that exposes a
difference in mentality where LeBron at
that point is like oh I'm the greatest
ever
Jordan was never like I'm the greatest
ever it's good he was just like I want
to do something they haven't done and
then when he did that what's the next
challenge
he wasn't like I'm sure he thought it
but he we haven't heard him openly say
that's when I knew I was the greatest
player ever
so LeBron has openly said I don't need
to achieve anything more I'm good
that's what you say when you say I'm the
greatest ever already after winning that
championship for Cleveland but here's
the thing Jordan to this day is like
it's maddening to me we didn't win seven
yeah
that's the difference yennefer yeah
they're Jordan the fact that Jordan will
never be satisfied after winning the NBA
Finals and hitting the game-winning shot
yeah okay of his final finals he goes
this is some daylight out here we can
get some golf swings in yeah yeah that
was yeah yeah
great point Ron is still in his career
going on accomplished everything I need
yeah Jordan hits the game-winner is like
let's go compete at something I am never
satisfied bottomless pit keep filling
keep filling keep filling and the fact
that LeBron is satisfied means he'll
live a much better life he'll probably
have a much better relationship with his
family and his friends and everything
LeBron and his wife seem happy LeBron
seems like a great guy got the [ __ ]
school that I promised Academy or
whatever I can
it's like this guy's incredible Jordan
is a more incredible basketball player
and there's a cost to being that in
criteria cost to winning Jordan said it
himself there's a cost to winning it's
happiness in a lot of times yeah yeah I
know look happy now
yeah it's maddening to me we didn't win
seven that don't seem happy
yeah it's just great that's shot of him
sitting on his whatever that thing is
bench yeah not like so yeah I should
dope shot that day no shot yeah somebody
had a meme of Thanos you know the end of
what is it endgame
yeah not the end but like midway through
the beginning of yeah oh just great yeah
just [ __ ] great anyway anything else
before we get out if I had any other any
other [ __ ] okay so after the doc was
over like whatever show that comes on
after they had that WNBA player Diana
Taurasi Rossi and she also said like oh
yeah when you're that competitive you're
sacrificing your life like she said all
right you won't I don't know why he the
greatest ever I guess and yeah she's
kind of like so she says like oh yeah
that's just you sacrifice your life your
life entire life is sacrificed and I
wonder you have that level of
competitiveness I wonder if it's easier
for them to sacrifice their life because
they're sad in their life you know like
their life does not fulfill them in the
way that basketball does so it's not a
difficult sacrifice whereas if you enjoy
life if you
joy spending time with your family if
you enjoy the little things in life it's
hard to sacrifice because you're getting
so much joy in the whole is being filled
by so many other things yeah if there
was only one thing that could fill that
hole for Jordan which was competition of
course she's gonna compete and of course
he's gonna lean into that far deeper
than anybody else
right because that was the only joy that
he got yeah yeah you're sacrificing more
but is it a sacrifice if that's the only
thing that makes you happy and then
you're telling these other guys who get
happiness from all these other things
the [ __ ] is wrong do you want you
sacrificing they're like fam you're
miserable out here doing this [ __ ] yeah
we love that [ __ ]
you're not sacrificing nothing matter
fact it's the least sacrifice for you
because you're miserable out there and
this is the only thing that makes you
happy
we're the ones really sacrificing cuz we
could get happiness out here we are
taking away our happiness yeah for this
thing that makes you happy
so maybe Jordans sacrifice the lease on
his team in terms of happiness right
maybe all those other players sacrifice
those years with him so that Jordan
could be happy he should be grateful for
them they gave way happiness man in a
short life they gave that [ __ ] away so
that Jordan could have his and was it
worth them along right absolutely
because you win rings but if you really
want to talk about sacrifice I don't
know if he sacrificed more and I don't
know how worth it it wasn't the long run
if you could rather if you could be
LeBron or be Jordan we would all want to
be LeBron in terms of like that guy
seems happy yeah Jordan greatest of all
time seems miserable I think I'd rather
be the second greatest of all time and
live a great life because the time
you're not playing is way longer the
time you're playing mm-hmm Jordan was
pro from 20 to 40 with two retirements
in between mmm-hmm so what's that
fifteen years he gonna live to be
seventy eighty that's 55 years you're
just sitting there miserable for 15
years of great I don't know that I'll
make that sacrifice if I can be LeBron
three chips did one for Cleveland did
everything you need to do bucket bucket
list second greatest ever and the guys I
was trunkful filled
[Applause]